the only thing we can be sure of about
the future is it will be absolutely
fantastic
[Music]
welcome everybody out there watching
this all over the internet and those of
you who are friends of UCSD and we are
pleased to welcome two alums of UC San
Diego bus stefanos pania who is located
at quantum design as long as as well as
Ivy Phipps who's also an alum of UCSD in
fact they both have the same advisors
Stefano for your PhD with Professor
Brian maple is now our chair and Ivy for
your master's degree and it's a pleasure
to welcome you guys both back and
Kwanzaa has been a huge supporter friend
and and kind of resource for for folks
far and wide and quite as that plays a
huge role in branches of physics as dye
versus material science quantum
information and even in cosmology the
stuff that we study in our laboratory
and they've been great partners and
friends so thank you guys coming back
okay Stefano is the chief technology
officer and Ivy is in charge of Quon
designs dilution refrigeration
technology and it's a tool that is used
well beyond this campus and well beyond
San Diego certainly and it has dramatic
implications for technology and what we
call fundamental physics revealing the
properties of matter and energy at its
coldest and most quantum state and it
has vast applications perhaps in you
know multitrillion-dollar business of
electronics eventually and and perhaps
even in quantum computing and things
like that so we hope to talk about that
in this in this little discussion so Ivy
you're in charge of dilution
refrigeration as I said a technology and
enables ultra low temperatures I always
think it's funny because you guys you
know I remember looking at quantum
designs website a long time ago even
before I came here around the time I
came here and thinking about San Diego
as a place I think of as really warm
nice balmy temperatures and the new up
technology that gets down how low Ivy
can you get down five zero mili Kelvin
so this is fifty one thousandth of a
degree above absolute
the temperature below which nothing can
be cooled and so this is really you've
been at the forefront of how we
understand materials and how they behave
at low temperatures and in the so called
degeneracy states when they behave
purely quantum mechanically you can't
describe them as little billiard balls
bouncing off of one another so it's
really wonderful to have you here and
first time so we start with personal
questions so nothing too personal no no
pin numbers will be revealed but but how
is it coming back to campus how often do
you get to come back to campus actually
it's always a great experience to see
the campus growing I get lost your
parking spaces by the day as you said a
lot of friends here at UCSD and this
relationship is really important to us
and that's why we you know we built our
first quantum design materials current
lab here at UCSB yeah cuz of this
collaboration yeah it's a wonderful
resource that we have uniquely I think
although many universities use your
technology and their demonstration labs
to have actually one that was dedicated
and donated by Kwan design for use for
our undergraduates and even some
graduate student sneaked in there on
occasion to learn about the properties
of low-temperature materials and that's
of course I think a hallmark of what you
guys do you make it really simple I mean
it's not simple to understand it or how
to build it
but you guys make it turnkey and explain
why maybe why is that important to your
users in the end and user side testing
it's like bulletproof and just works
every time
time it takes less time some labs want
the understanding the fundamental
understanding of how their systems are
running other labs that's not their
focus that does need to be their focus
they can immediately access what they
would like to research and time is money
resources are short and supply right now
that's a big deal yeah it's really
wonderful to have that resource and also
to you know start as early in the stem
pipeline as possible training these you
know undergrads to learn how to operate
this technology which is you know
turnkey but they still have that nuts
and bolts understanding
physics that goes into it so we
educators really appreciate that
so maybe just Stefano you can describe
how is it that the superconducting
devices things like squids and exotic
and and kind of creepy crawly things
that we use in our technology and
cosmology how are they used around the
world and what's kuan designs role in
fabricating them and enabling them
really for scalability so quantum design
is really the leading provider of
nanotechnology tools around the globe
and that includes the squids you know
our design of all team film squid it
really was a breakthrough when he came
and we used squids as you know
instruments in the squid magnetometer to
measure really tiny magnetic moments of
materials and people in fact use the
NPMs the MPM s3 this is the third
generation of 30 years of combination of
putting squids into instruments really
to research new compounds new
superconducting compounds and discover
even higher transition temperatures for
superconductors and we buy widely used
as detectors in cosmology as well and
you know there's four geophysical
applications there's squids
so the the general terms for these
squids is is really a magnetic flux to
voltage converter that really that's
what the actual device does and be able
to use it is it's it's difficult because
it's sensitivity not only it's the
greatest strength but it's also its
greatest weakness it's because you have
to shield everything else that be moving
that you don't want to measure by the
squid so you have to do it correctly
there are these use in any medical
applications of course yeah so does the
patient have to be cooled down to 50
milli cos IV actually do that all the
time
[Music]
people say Alexa see ya up Olympics is
yours or so their study yeah they're
used for that mm-hmm it's a brainwave
sensing so these devices the
superconducting quantum interference
devices I believe I have that right they
can sense you know things that are
basically a one quantum of magnetism so
the smallest possible magnetic fields
that could be many many times billions
of times you know smaller than the
Earth's magnetic field maybe even a
trillions and magnetic fields are very
hard to block and shield out so to get
something this reliable in the lab in
the field in diagnostic or clinic
offices really impressive but you do
more than kind of that sort of applied
technology which is used for you know
Diagnostics or medical things as I said
or even in our field where we're using
them as amplifiers for detecting these
ultra faint signals from the cosmic
microwave background radiation a lot of
what other people do using these around
the world I remember going to your to
your facility to the factory and seeing
all the places that you're sending these
machines out to around the world and do
you guys get to go to these places and
visit with with potential customers or
is that is that not the chief technology
officer isn't it role in though that's
certainly not my role although they do
keep trying to ship me out with the DRS
certainly one of the satisfaction you
know I think one of the questions later
on is what what is mostly appreciate
about your work and it's really seeing
our technology used in the by
researchers the end users and how the
technology that we design into these
instruments that often is so hard to
create from from scratch you know from
fundamental principle how that gives an
edge to our instruments compared to
other products that might be out there
and how that really has a huge impact on
the automate recent research of
scientists and there's been many times
you mean the company history where our
instruments have really fueled some
major breakthroughs even the first quit
magnetometer the NPMs became highly
instrument right after the discovery I
TC superconductors accumulated in 1987
with the Woodstock of physics after that
we were inundated by orders for the
magnetic property measurement system
that's the NES implements the niba today
that really remains the instrument of
choice for researchers who are looking
for new compounds superconducting
compounds that have even higher
transition temperatures and in terms of
breakdown that's probably your dominant
you know kind of customer or you know
the product that you guys are producing
but lately you've also been getting more
and more into dilution refrigeration I
thought maybe IV you could explain first
of all what is dilution refrigeration
for those that may not be familiar out
there what does it do as I said you you
have that cold this part of San Diego on
a typical day and down down in the
valley where you guys work and and these
are kind of I usually describe it when
someone asked me for a technical
description of me where I say it's magic
and that you're a miracle happens here
and functioning what do they do and you
flip a switch and what happens well ours
is a button because that's what we
specialize in we provide the easy user
interfaces but essentially with your
normal physical properties measurement
system a PBMs system you can access down
to two kelvin there abouts and the 50
millikelvin comes from the more or less
cryostat within your cryostat Allah your
dilution refrigerator so it has two
modes of operation when it's just pure
like normal evaporative pumping
evaporative cooling process where you
just purely removing energy from it
that'll access certain temperature range
there abouts one Kelvin but it'll allow
you have a continuous measurement down
to it rather than having the disjoint of
which thermometers in control and a
seamless integration of temporal control
and then we have the delusion cooling
phase which is where the interplay
between the helium 3 and helium for
isotopes actually become a bit more
important that is where we get our 50
millikelvin cooling power but it is the
energetic exchange between those
isotopes that is really the niche of
dilution refrigeration and these devices
they you know consume helium like as you
were and you and I were graduate
students we go to dump in vast
quantities of liquid helium which at the
time cost about the same amount as you
know fine Italian wine but now it's
gotten much more expensive so you
presumably don't need any of these
consumable liquid helium supplies
correct it is a closed system so once
the mixture is set after a while of
course helium is a very small atom so
after a while but it will deplete but
that's decade so for a decade you have
the same source of healing that's a
that's a big deal because you're only
paying that expenditure once maybe a
second time depending on maintenance or
other things that can potentially go
wrong but that's the same that's way
less than any of the big cryo stats and
having to potentially like leak check
that and all the ways that things can be
improved fourth hour duration or sager
it's gonna be you know pretty minimal
compared to the big cryostat yep so yeah
is there are there challenges and
listeners out on our audience may have
heard about the global helium shortage
that's ongoing
obviously you use some ordinary isotopic
helium four which has two protons two
neutrons helium-3 is one fewer neutrons
so it has two protons two one Neutron is
there a shortage of helium-3 as well as
a shortage of helium four there's never
enough teams right you know right now I
think the prices are coming down a
little bit so it would indicate that
there is a you know normal supply but
there is never enough and you know ilium
in general is is the fuel of our
business you know we we are dependent on
liquid in liquefying helium for testing
our instruments and you know if you do a
short flashback twenty twelve seven
years ago quantum design was consuming
about ten thousand liters of liquid
helium per month that's hundred twenty
thousand liters of liquid helium
millions ago we put it work because it
was calibrating our instruments
validating you know calibration of
customer units but the same time was
also waste because all the helium was
was basically released to the atmosphere
and lost forever so after a while this
became unsustainable because of helium
shortages around the world and then the
fact that the price kept increasing so
we really set ourselves to create a line
of products for our customers where they
can not only recycle the helium but
liquefy it and we ourselves have
installed a pre-major helium plant at
quantum design so that the helium can be
recovered purified and liquefied again
and as a comparison seven years later
now we are using 18 thousand liters of
indium which is an 85% reduction of
helium consumption over 7 years ago so
and it gets better you know we are
really committed at trying to keep this
helium molecule as much as we can on
earth and as analogy our chief operating
officers always says that every day we
basically fill up about 3000 balloons
and but instead of letting it go we
actually use them at three weddings
before we actually release them into the
sky so you know this is really where
Elin conservation comes in play trying
to keep the helium working for this
industry as much as possible and that's
why I'm July 10th of this year we a
quantum design at launch helium
conservation day and there was a very
pretty major event quantum design that
was also there was a webinar on it and
many people from all around the world
contributed clips from their labs to say
how they were recycling helium and the
event is really want to commemorate the
of course the great Dutch physicist
commonly omnis who liquefy the helium in
1908 and for the first time but at the
same time
increase awareness about the helium
helium is an art of renewable sort then
once it's lost into the atmosphere is
gone forever yeah and we want to do our
part in not only enabling our customers
to recover it but do it here at the
factory no no and often times people
talk and I feel the cosmology that you
know humans are made of starstuff but
you know actually we're also made of a
lot of stuff that was produced in the
Big Bang which is if hydrogen and
isotopes of hydrogen but also a little
bit of helium and some of that helium if
not all of that helium that that we you
know find our local local part of the of
the universe shall we say or a great
deal of it was produced in the Big Bang
and there's only you know there's only
one Big Bang that we know about for sure
and so it's hard to think about
renewables in that sense so we got to be
careful with what we do have I want to
move on to some of the applications of
dilution refrigeration and people have
heard a lot of interesting of advances
in quantum computing and many different
maybe competitors or maybe other you
know colleagues or so forth in the field
of quantum materials are using dilution
refrigeration to get down to low
temperatures to operate these new
devices which have so much promise
potentially for solving very previously
intractable problems in computer science
and physics and simulations and math
biology etc can you say something IV
about potential applications or how
people are using dilution refrigeration
to enable research or development in
quantum computing I think the
application would be more for assessing
the quality of the quantum materials
that would eventually be utilized with
quantum computing the whole bread and
butter of the our cutie donation
refrigerator is that we can do these
experiments quickly some of the bigger
price that's take at least like a week
to prepare and they can measure many
samples at a time but that's a week if
not a month of preparation for hopefully
a successful measurement we can do it in
eight hours
that's how you test the materials that
would go into the comm Aquatica huh
so we can carry we can fully
characterize the material before it's
designed incorporation into something
called a quantum computer okay that's
where I would consider our bread and
butter to be really in the contribution
to quantum because it was not another
MPM mass or is it a low temperature
because the one you described earlier is
of one Kelvin it's just this June in
June 2019 some measurements on a new
material quantum material a pie chloride
a single crystal discovered we helped
make some measurements IC susceptibility
measurements on this material and and by
scientists the quantum design Manan even
nylon that performed the measurements
and he helped a collaboration of
international collaboration of
scientists that was led by pan shank Bay
at Rice University in discovering a new
quantum material and they believe that
this is the first experimental
verification of discovering a quantum
spin liquid as you know the quantum
speak liquids were first postulated by
Philip Anderson and Nobel laureate in
1973 and he took 46 years to basically
discover this this material this
material is attracted a lot of a lot of
attention because of its properties
where the spin that basically the atomic
lattice of the material doesn't let the
spin or order in any form and therefore
it can be really used for creating
qubits and so since in 1980 there's been
a lot of interest both in
superconductivity trying to explain
superconductivity using this quantum
squiggly quantum spin liquids and also
the fact that there may be unable to
create qubits for a quantum computer so
it's the dilution refrigerators are
we used our dilution refrigerators are
really used by material scientists they
want to focus on discovering the next
generation of quantum materials that
would eventually fuel going to devices
that would fuel the quantum computing
revolution of the future so while our
instruments are delicious noodles are
rather small and they cannot be built
into a quantum computer really used for
another purpose and more fundamental
purpose which is discovering new
materials that enables quantum
technology in the basic properties
fundamental physics that go into good
so I'm finish up with a couple questions
about your relationship to UCSD s as I
said UCSD is benefited a lot from from
quantum design and vice-versa
so how did your education here and
experiences that you had here shape
where you ended up today I'll start with
IB many I have I suppose a simple answer
to that I was in Brian maples lab I
started there as an undergraduate work
there as a lab tech was able to be in
the right place at the right time for
one a Chifa a technical officer from
quantum design came over to Brian's lab
and asked if there was anybody that
would be interested in an internship
okay yes yes please thank you very much
so I ended up doing my masters at within
brian's lab but with the material
sciences and engineering programs so I
might my degrees do cover physics
material sciences and engineering and
had a great time doing it Brian's lab
afforded me a lot of opportunities the
least of which is being able to
transition to a career with quantum
design yeah and what about you you know
I was very very fortunate to you know to
work in Brian's lab he wasn't I earned
my PhD and there's that guidance and you
know Brian really taught me I was a
great mentor really taught me to to
really great attributes to become not
only a good researcher but eventually a
leader of a Tekonsha company and that is
that you really have to
work through challenges and problems
that will occur in whatever you are
pursuing and and be tenacious and really
looking to a successful completion of a
research project and also be very
flexible because as you discover things
you may find out new solutions that take
you to a different path that again may
be even more rewarding of what you are
seeking to begin with so be flexible
Internationa sand that's something that
really I think I got from Brian yeah
yeah I also benefit from from my co
namesake Brian and he's he's an
invaluable resource he's such a such a
wonderful figure in this University's
history and certainly in the in the
company that that you guys are a part of
I want to finish up with you know what
for kind of a opportunity for you guys
to speak to a future you know person and
maybe like Ivy is now you know now or
wanting to be where Ivy is now and
wanting to know what's the best part of
your job what do you like most about the
you know opportunities and resources and
so forth that you have a quantum design
it's it's almost odd that the culture
con design is not that much different
than the culture at the lab that I came
from you know it inspires
open-mindedness it inspires conversation
about difficult problems regardless of
whether the people you're talking about
are within that same field or within
that same product but the
open-mindedness for conversation for
problem solving and and just different
perspectives that's something that I
know that Stefano has carried through
and because I came after I definitely
saw that transition and it's it's
wonderful to be able to work with a
group of people that have that
generosity of spirit generosity of their
time because everybody is busy but they
they will stop and and just figure it
out and you know sometimes like Cepheid
I was saying different perspectives lead
to different pathways of thinking which
lead to different solutions that one
don't really wouldn't have come to on
their own
and that's a very very vital part of at
least our industry I'm assuming any
company would benefit from those
dynamics but specifically for a
technologically based company that has
to stay on the forefront of innovation
that's an important dynamic to have
within a group yeah whenever I go down
there I've been been permitted on the
campus there a couple times and the
thing I always recommends the curiosity
and the passion of the people that work
there for it you know the from the line
you know worker - all the way up to the
managers there's this relentless
curiosity and passion for what they're
the mission of the company and what
about you what are your well I think I
ever talked to before about you know
being really my you know satisfaction of
this this job is really seeing our
instruments used by end users and also
collaborating with them and listening to
them to what they need you know at the
end of the day we are instrument makers
and we're trying to solve a problem
really not something esoteric but you
know we enjoy and engage with
researchers and we find out what is that
you're trying to do and for instance
that's how the heat capacity
measurements that we have engineered and
now it's an automated system is probably
one of our most best-selling measurement
options was something that a lot of
people came to us and said you know it
would be really great to do the heat
capacity measurements but you can't do
it it's really hard to do right and you
know for us to go to the you know the
tamasha see of like doing it and then
really find a way way there wasn't done
before and making something that is now
used worldwide everywhere I mean
literally there are tens if not hundreds
of papers per month that come out are in
scientific journals from our instruments
Lee that's a tremendous amount of
product that we have there and I can
imagine well Ivy Phipps and Stephano
Spagna thank you so much for coming back
to your alma mater and sharing some of
your experiences acorn design with us
the future looks incredibly bright and
promising and
there with all your capabilities thank
you so much again thank you thank you
for having us the only thing we can be
sure of about the future is it will be
absolutely fantastic
[Music]
you
you